Banana bread is probably the thing I bake most in our house,
and I had a lot of bananas that were very ripe,
so I use those up to make the best banana bread.
Don't throw your brown bananas away.
So many ways you can use them,
and they're especially good in banana bread.
So I started by mashing up three to four bananas depending on the size.
You can add some more cracking in an egg.
Instead of sugar, I use some maple syrup,
some vanilla extract,
melted butter,
however much cinnamon your heart desires.
Give that a really good mix
before adding in some baking powder and baking soda.
I like this recipe because everything stays in one bowl,
so less clean up.
I add some flour to that,
give that really good mix,
and then I usually add some chocolate chips or nuts to the mixture
and make sure they're incorporated really well
before burning my batter into my loaf pan
and popping it in the oven for about an hour.
Usually I would let this cool completely in the loaf pan,
but we couldn't wait today.
So I cut a slice and top it with some butter.